ce prix monsieur le président madame la
ministre monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues aujourd'hui nous nous
retrouvons à débattre que l'énergie car
disons le franchement nous traversons
une crise une crise que personne n'avait
vu venir une crise provoquée par une
conjonction d'événements et de facteur
imprévu qui se sont additionnés pour
provoquer une explosion des prix du gaz
qu'il gagne de proche en proche tous les
marchés de l'énergie et révèle la
faillite de l'europe dans ce domaine
cette même europe qui bâtit sur la seule
concurrence a choisi d'exposer
l'ensemble de l'économie et des ménages
à la volatilité des marchés
il faut être clair la crise que nous
connaissons n'est ni lié à une hausse de
la consommation ni à une augmentation
des coûts de production mais c'était la
libéralisation du secteur que l'on doit
la situation pour laquelle nous sommes
de fait le système actuel ne permet même
pas de financer les investissements
nécessaires car ils n'offrent aucune
visibilité
un changement de cap doit être
rapidement mener autrement il risque
d'être impossible de mener une
transition écologique acceptée par
l'ensemble des populations
l'origine de cette dépendance
énergétique est multiple si la faiblesse
de la politique européenne de l'énergie
en est une la crise économique de 2008 a
aussi découragé certains états membres à
investir dans des infrastructures
énergétiques ou dans la rénovation leurs
infrastructures vieillissantes dans ce
contexte morose de nombreux pays hors
union ont aussi profité de l'absence
d'autoroutes de l'énergie entre les 28
pour signer des partenariats
d'approvisionnement avec certains
d'entre eux
confronté à l'hystérie des marchés
l'europe avance en ordre dispersé chaque
gouvernement tente de limiter la casse
pour sa population depuis le milieu de
l'été une poignée de pays européens
notamment l'espagne et l'italie mais
aussi la france ont déjà adopté des
mesures telles que l'allègement de la
fiscalité indirecte un chèque énergie
pour les ménages les plus pauvres le gel
provisoire des hausses dans la sur
taxation des profits des électriciens et
2 gaziers pour tenter d'aider les
consommateurs à faire face à l'envolée
des prix
l'ensemble de ces aides représenterez
quelques 18 milliards d'euros rien que
pour la france ces mêmes aides ont pu
être octroyés en tendant le bras à
bruxelles la présidence tournante de
l'europe n'est pas étrangère à ce passe
passe budgétaire qu'ils auraient pu le
rappeler un article du canard enchaîné
ce même jour mais cela est tout
bonnement insuffisants et les
consommateurs peinent à avoir la
traduction concrète dans leur pouvoir
d'achat de plus des mesures prix se font
au détriment du contribuable en cela la
situation française est quelque peu
ubuesque et éclairant des dérives de la
libéralisation à outrance du marché
d'énergie
vous avez interrogé à ce sujet le
ministre de l'économie de la semaine
dernière lors des questions au
gouvernement j'avais demandé comment
nous pouvions nous trouver dans une
situation où edf produisent et une
électricité qu elle ne pouvait vendre
elle-même au prix du marché mais qu'elle
devait céder à ses concurrents qui eux
pratiquer des prix exorbitants
j'attends encore la réponse je ne doute
pas qu'aujourd'hui vous serez à même de
me l'apporté car des questions
financières et monétaires se pose de
plus en plus précisément cette crise
énergétique
place la banque centrale européenne dans
une position difficile contre cette
flambée contre cette inflation importée
elle ne peut rien faire mais bon coup
mais combien de temps pourra t elle
maintenir sa politique monétaire et les
toons et les taux faibles
de fait ne nous leurrons pas
la crise risque de durer bien plus
longtemps que ce que vous escomptez les
eaux sur le marché du gaz se sont
propagées aux marchés l'électricité du
charbon du pétrole mais maintenant elles
engagées elles ont gagné les marchés des
flotteurs des contrats
d'approvisionnement d'électricité pour
2022 voire 2023 se négocie au prix de
150 euros le mégawatt contre 39 euros en
moyenne en 2019
c'est un signe que les intervenants de
marché n'anticipe pas de baisse rapide
in et d'acteurs blement ces prix se
répercuteront à un moment ou un autre
dans les factures des ménages et aux
mesures de bricolage conjoncturelle ne
changeront pas la donne au risque de
provoquer un malaise social encore plus
grand